hello everyone
this is cassian carmill i am the
director of
research and development at demonics uh
today we're going to be talking about
implementing ips derived 3d
and urestroid for fast tracking novel
target and
identification in the first in a human
first drug discover paradigm
so it's a long title but
i think it's going to be very
interesting uh first a disclaimer uh
and workers thermomix we are our
expertise in the human ips derived
tissue
um special neurosteroids and organoids
where that is biology reach platforms to
high food proof screening
and one particular that's going to be
talking today a lot
is is the new platform that we have or
our
experience with the neural platform that
you call microbrain so
um i not of course referred
uh i will be talking about a lot but our
experience
that and how that could improve or help
to to
replace or refine the use of animal
in research
so i'm going to have two main parts
on this presentation the first part
we're going to be talking about these
human neurodestroyed platform our
experience that have acquired
over the years so introduce a
humanitarian right to be the ice
screening platform
and discuss the key effects of this
english system that's able to reduce
replace or refine uh anybody using
pre-clinical research
and the part two we're going to use on
one example or a case study for a
neurotic proper disorder more specific
rat syndrome
that's an autism-like disorder is uh
using this ips derived
neurospheroids from the disorder to
demonstrate how this platform can be
used for wrapped uh
target and heat electrification
validation and finally provide
an example of clinical translation uh
using business screening platform
so you all are probably very familiar
with the models that are being available
for pre-clinical research so there is
basically two main models that's the
aviator model
and the in-vivo model so um um
usually the in-vehicle represents a bit
more complexity there they have complex
physiology
um they have multiple cell types
interacting with
also are very important especially some
disease uh
case uh however the immediate model has
several adventures like
this is scalable are early uh easy
access
and less expensive than the the
individual model the
the main problem is that um they usually
lack the complexity
that you're going to require for for the
physiology for
what a complete organism especially a
human
model um in the other case and in the i
mean in their
hands they do have um because they're
scalable they do have this is a bit of
being applying a high fructose scale
that usually is harder to apply
with uh the indeed models even animal
models are very expensive to do at scale
and these models these silver models are
usually
are a little bit cheaper however as
anyone is familiar when you're talking
about screening or
research and click link research is that
there is no perfect model right so there
are several
um different caveats of using these
specific models for example the so
the 2d solar model they do not
reconciliate complex human physiology
there are very simple models usually the
one cell type only or a fuel cell type
only
the the most promising obvious impedes
tomorrow the organized model they're
they suffer from huge availability
between the different
um steroids different organoids
the animal model the ones that are going
to be focused uh do not fully break up
with the
human physiologist a lot of disorders or
diseases that are really hard to
to mimic and to to uh
tomorrow using an animal model and
they're also very expensive
and finally the the brain here that
represents the post-mortem tissue
um usually just repentance enough shots
that they're really hard to get
um and you can uh you're only getting
what's available
to you and you usually use a snapshot of
the disease or any point of the disease
after
uh after the person die for example you
can have access to the tissue
so they are used for validation uh but
it's really hard to
to do a research preclinical research
based on postmod only postmortem tissue
so one of the the
the main caveats of the individual model
is like how you now
can have relevant tissue in vitro that
can
now help to to drive free clinical
research right and
one of the big breakthroughs uh uh
in the past was the the uh discover of
the reprogramming
uh to create induced purpose and stem
cells right so
um these cells are able to differentiate
towards any tissue in the body
and because you you with the
ribogramming now you can reprogram any
cell
to this poor important stage now have
access to a diverse genetic background
right basically you can take cells
foundations or fiberglass foundations
and use those fibroblasts to to
differentiate towards this tissue so
they're a human derived tissue they're
scalable because you can
expand the cells and you give it access
to a lot of the diverse
genetic backgrounds so there is also
finally several protocols
available for this that's able to create
a tissue pattern towards this
tissue of interest for example neural
tissue or cardiac tissue and so on
there's two main models available 2d
models and
the 3d models that i better refer are
organized and this case here is showing
that the brain organized
that usually have is a complex tissue
have multiple cell types have the
organization but you cannot mimic
intentionally
one of the main categories of the
organoids is the fact that they're
variable
so with that uh
in mind um one of the things that
emerges
is less variable uh 3d cultures right so
um and to to be able to contribute
uh for pre-clinical resources a lot of
things that
these 3d issues need to have one of the
key features for this human ips
directorate each cookers
is that they first provide access to a
diversion at backgrounds as i mentioned
because you can reprogram ips from
patients now have access to a lot of
disease lines
they are composed of co-culture of
multiple cell types and a lot of
diseases these are very important for
example
the example that's shown here is a cross
section of
one um asteroid a neurosteroid that's
composed of neurons and astrocytes
cortical neurons and court cholesterol
sites that's very important for some
cortical disorders
and the interaction between this just
cells is really important um
you can even see in a high resolution
how these cells interact in 3d and you
start to see that
this 3d interaction the cells are really
close together
and then the astrocytes and neurons are
interacting into it in a way that
more closely resemble what's normally uh
found in the
immediate tissue uh these are also
active
right so this needs to be functional
tissue and uh one of the characters
going back to this neuronal tissue that
we have it here
is that they present synchronized
neuronal activity
and finally because we're doing this uh
from um
um in the individual resisting industry
system coming from ipscs
you can now scale this for four
platforms for hyphen pool or high
content screening platforms in this case
you could use like three four-wheel
plates for example
and have these in in um in a format that
would allow you to screen several
compounds at the same time so
you you will have an adventure today in
vivo
uh systems that now in a small format
you are able to
screen several compounds at the same
time
so uh in summary uh this uh neo-resource
the desirable individual uh
uh model for a hyperboost gaining
they need to have they need first the
correct cell types in this case as i
mentioned
at least the cortical neurons and
astrocytes
they need to have the correct gene
expression and they do express
a lot of the key features or key neurons
transmitters that
are uh the the markers of vanilla tissue
and they need to have the correct
functionality in this case
uh neuronal tissue they are electro
active cells
and what you can observe want to observe
this tissue that you have
they would have done in the lab is that
um they're
have the correct electrophysiology in
this case represented by ada that
multi electrode array electric discharge
but they also
uh you can also see this
electrophysiology
indirectly using calcium fluctuation so
you have a concentration that's able to
have this force that's
shown here by causal oscillations on
flipper so uh
and the flipper is just a calcium reader
a high fructose reader
and what you saw is that these calcium
oscillations
represent the synchronized works that
visual network is showing that
is quite interesting from a neural
standpoint
[Music]
we are also able to modulate this
activity what's really important because
not the activity the t shouldn't be
active but need to be relevant all right
you need to be
correct the the correct hygiene
expression
or neurotransmitters that are able to
modulate that activity and you can
modulate these active
agonies or antagonists of specific
neurotransmitters that
are present on this tissue and this is
just showing the modulation of the
calcium
activity so you're modulating the the
causal waves or causing frequency
of the peaks that observe uh using this
uh
platform
one one thing that you really want to
apply this a large scale
and to together or to replace some of
the animal used in clinical research
is that these need to be reproducible
over time so not
only batch to batch but for experimental
experiments so you need to find
the same modulation that you find uh
with the previous patterns which is
really important because uh high
fructose claims platforms to be
classified as hyper we need to be able
to be reproducible over time
and also you need to be able to
manufacture with that scale right you
need to be able to
to demand this uh to several research
several labs at the same time or to your
demand
on the research that you have um if you
can only reproduce a very few
that this may not be feasible for the
kind of research that we're doing so
these are all the key features that
these uh platforms need to have it to be
able
to to to start to to replace or start to
think about
uh they use a cocoon that you use with
animal uh
imperculating research so just to
summarize
they need to have relevant cell types to
expect physiology
and they have a robust screen platform
that needs to have all these
functional characteristics that they
mentioned
so um this uh across the world there are
several labs using these platforms for
different things uh and there's
different uses that can be done
uh we particularly have used some of
this these 3d models so you have used
with human ips derived
models uh for genetic disorder studies
so i'm going to show one example
for functional high throughput screening
we start id and compound specification
this is only during the drug screening
uh drug discover scenario but you can
also use for state pharmacology or talks
for example for early housing
identification for neurotoxicity or
environment toxic screening uh and
finally you can even use it for
for for a new disease modeling for
example we can use
these 3d models and integrate the new
cell types on this
uh for example we could use um this uh
neurosteroids that's basically
representation of the brain and then
integrates glioblastoma lines
to study a cancer model uh your envy
cells
so just in summer for the part one uh it
takes these human ips to drive to the
models
and give it they give access to a lot of
relevant biology
uh in vitro right um they are a scalable
and reproducible platform for
preservative interrogation it is really
important when they're talking about the
hyperpool
uh screening platform and finally they
can better recapitulate the complexity
of the human tissue is comparably 2d
of course there is still a gap between
what you can find
in vivo but at least these individual
models are
trying to close the gap between the day
individual
theater and this is really important
there are steps that's in the right
direction and that's why it's really
important
to go towards that um one thing that
there is no perfect model
no perfect screen model for for
everything there is the caveats of the
vehicle there is the caveat of the
individual but if you have the right
questions for that model you can have
very powerful answers
and some of these questions can be a red
answer on the invisible model
and they're going to show one example uh
and the parts too that should
apply this form this is modeling context
and why we use the nanospheroids as a
perfect tool to identify
uh forcing chronic targets and compounds
the disease that we're going to be
studying discussion here is called red
cinnamon so it's
in the autism spectrum although it's a
little bit more severe than autism
itself and
classified aside is the x-linkage
disorder
with males being more severe effect so
it's a very different disease to model
uh individuals so there is some
individual models these are some mouse
models for this
but they not really recapitulate what
you're seeing um in the
animal uh species so so this
interstitial difference
is really hard to to to be recognized in
this particular
model for this particular disorder so
that's where it came with the in vitro
model
so as i mentioned the the the
spectrum of phenotypes go from autism
like behavior seizures and a lot of
language so it can be very severe
and most of the mutations are located in
62 gene
so more than 95 percent of the case so
we took two different lines one control
line that's a male
a line as a parental control for the
disease line and another business line
that's
uh is also male that's a nonsense
mutation in n72 gene
so it's basically an account for for
that protein and the very severe
phenotype
the patient has a very severe phenotype
or manifestation of the disease
then one of the first thing was uh to
develop
these nd 3d space right develop these
three destroys that
was mentioned and see if there is uh
they're able to
to generate these destroys in a very
imogenous way
uh because it is very important if you
want to replace or use this in high
quality screenings
and uh here's a snapshot on the left on
the top
for for three to four okay so three four
well asteroids or mini brains that
happen this for the red
this is effect and for the controls uh
on the bottom here you can have a bright
field image
of both of these as well red
and control and on the right here you
have a graph
of the size of the diameter of the
destroys over time so you can see that
even if you play it
very homogeneous in the beginning over
time they have a field type already just
in
in the side so there is a cellular
phenotype that they are observing this
over time on these steroids and this is
very consistent
uh one thing that you can also do is
start to play with these uh
3d models with input models that now you
can also imagine mix for example as i
mentioned we started a male model that's
basically
um there is all the cells contain the
mutation but this is the
excellent disorder in the females you
usually have a mosaicism
in the brain we have some neurons that
express
the the mutant form and some neurons
that express the
uh the the y-type form the correct form
so
we could now take these cells that have
the lab and mix
to match this mosaicism so we're going
to a called mosaicism of one to one and
now we have a phenotype that's
usually in between the the the white
type and the red
the 100 red and that's what's quite
interesting to observe
so one one thing that we can do as well
with this mod is like let's uh
interrogate
is there is there the correct cell
composition there right
remember that uh one of the dimensions
is individual models that now you have
can have complex cultures uh in theater
is really important
for several disorders uh one of the main
dimensions of the organs because you
have the complex tissue there
and there is many case for main
disorders that this complex future is
really important to the manifestation of
the phenotype
and so when you're talking about
replacing uh in the model we need to
consider that
physiology to consider this um
these complex models in vitro to be able
to recapitulate the disease in a level
that you can
have a phenotype that's relevant to the
disease in vivo
and here you can observe that you do
have the correct cell types better
targeted that's neuroblastocytes deals
in green biomass to staining
and vasocites in red by jessie b stein
in both control and red
neospheroids uh you also
observe a diverse
field type in
red phenotype on the sculptures and
molecular cellular and functional level
so these are going just for what was
described in the literature and see
if you can recapitulate those difference
and you did observe in the gene
expression different express genes
uh between red and white type then uh we
also observe a silver context that's
uh the number of synaptic points between
red and a white type
reducing the rest and finally this
accumulated with a
functional phenotype that's basically a
difference
between red and white type activity
electro activity
so another way to measure the electro
activity as i mentioned
before was through the calcium activity
right so in this caution you can do the
high footprint scale because you can now
do
in 384 wells and this uh is just showing
two uh wells uh so two different traces
for control and two tracings for rat
uh regardless spontaneous neuronal
activity so spontaneous calcium activity
here
so and we can already see that diffusion
you can see a check for us
there right one thing that's key when
you have this
biological data is like how you're going
to extract the data and
one thing that you had to develop
because there was not available
was algorithms that are able to extract
this data and quantify the difference
um on these two different phenotypes
that we're observing
between control and red and finally
one thing that's key for progressing
this is a hyperpro
option uh uh or high quality screen
platform is
that is reproducible right so between
different patches
of this differentiation we're able to
have the same phenotypes and
phenotypes that are reproducible
so one of the key things that
we have done is trying to combine these
data science with
this biological data to extract the
right pictures right so we have these
heat certifications that's really
important is it really challenging the
people right now
because uh you need to have a huge data
set of biological data to try to extract
these pictures
and this can be easily achieved with
these models that you know have in a
high proof fashion but
half of the institute for reform to have
tons of the data points by virtual data
points that you can now use
to train uh these ai or always that
we're developing
to make sure that they extract the right
features uh so in this example we start
with calcium tracing futures
uh we uh we start to
extract the features from these calcium
wastes that observe
and then you can rank and summarize this
data in a data pot of restrooms so we
can
we can quantify the raster based on the
controls and see
how close is after treatment you can you
can reach
the control levels of the activity
so for this particular study uh we
decided to use what's called this mic
library so it's marked as a collection
of compounds that were invented for
for for uh red team it's composed of 296
compounds at 10 millimolars
and we did the primary screening at one
micromotor so you select one
concentration
and the secondary screen at multiple
concentrations we use the four
replicates per dosage because this uh
was easy enough you could use four
replicates you could use
four uh plates you can achieve all this
and uh we did the chronic treatment for
four weeks these are patients that's
gonna be
um uh for treatment for life so remember
that you wanna mimic the correct
physiology here
and um these patients are they're going
to have the mutation they're going to
have this dusty
on the cells so you need to make sure
that the
treatment is long enough to correct the
what needs to be correct it don't cause
any side effects
so i'm going to show three different
examples of what's expected and what you
can find
one of the examples here the first
example is when you don't have
treated compounds you know those
dependent and you don't have
any rescue uh moreover at high
concentration start to have some
toxicity so the
the system uh um the beauty of this kind
of systems that's able to even then
fight toxicity at the high dosage
so what you can see here that increase
the the concentration of
the the compound and there is four
replicates of the treated red
at some point you start to have no
stigma anymore so there is a functional
toxicity there
that can lead to side effects in
patients as well so it needs to be
system is able to capture that and
extract this information as well
you can also uh extract cell health for
the atp contents of seal
of itself and see if there is any any uh
decay on the the cell health after the
treatment we can have the high dosage
and this can be hand-to-hand if the
biological data that we have the
functional data that we have
here uh there is uh this example that we
have a good rescue so we already
increased the concentration we have
adult
dependent rescue of the cells and the
stigma start to become
better and better over the
concentrations and there is no silver
decay and finally if there is a
another example that you do have a
rescue at
a certain concentration but as you
increase the concentration we start to
have side effects which is a very common
like uh
if um you there's some compounds
that they can have a benefit on the
disease but at the same
time as including the concentration you
can have
also side effects on this and this
system functional
assets like this one that hyphen whiskey
are able to capture these potential side
effects
and remember that this is a human
t-shirt that sometimes can be missed
on the indeed invisible model so it's
really nice to go ahead and understand
this model
with the individual model that you have
with the animal models to see if
this also can be observed in medical
models
so finally uh what you do with all these
biological data that extract you do
then uh hit the notification and rank
organ again
we're developing the new algorithm
should do this and there's a lot of
research being done on these sets
now that you have these biological data
so combine these uh
biological data that's in the hyper
proof so you have large lipos data
with advanced analytics to to stratify
the most effective compounds and targets
and now you start to rank the ones that
have good rescue and no toxins no
functional toxins there are no cellular
toxicity
and with compounds that would move
forward and this can already start to
filter
more compounds before they go to animal
use or before they go through
to clinical research
so here's one example of what we found
is basically
that's a phenotypically recovered by
target for
so you can see that there are several
targets that was composed on this
mic library um and
uh you you can see here the ones on the
the right is just the legend of
what's considered rescue or not so
everything that was
green or blue was considered some
recorder of this
and uh red is the one that
not only didn't recover but had a side
effect so the decreasing activity
that could affect uh the patient so
we exclude those compounds and just
focus on the ones that are in green
and blue and you can see there a bit
this that's
um based on the concentration there is a
diverse
um um some that work some that didn't
work but
when you give a deep diving in
particular mechanisms of actions for
example they call an energy system
then uh you start to observe something
very very interesting uh if you go
focus only the cholinergic system then
uh
you have algorithms antagonists that
have a mix of work and didn't work and
in fact most of them didn't work
but when you focus on the acetyl
conditions inhibitors
there is from seven compounds six have a
recover some level of
5 with a good very good recovery so this
is already indication that this class of
compounds for this disease is really
important
uh a class that can be a part of this
so when we move forward with this uh
this hit validation that now you can do
um in uh in
in this platform as well you start to
observe that
um it's in a dose dependent matter you
you have this rescue
so we removed four four compounds for
visual federation
in all these four compounds in the
acetylcholinesterase inhibitor class
they were able to rescue the
female type of rats and we did it uh a
five years for cedar
pump and the ama electrophysiology they
also observed this rescue so this is a
very powerful indication that
it's primary screening that you can do
at high fructose scale
now can move uh and be validated through
secular assays uh
to move towards preclinical research so
our compounds will confirm the rest with
no components induce control line
uh side effects of or uh
in other words we also test this
compound concentration in control lines
to make sure that there is no
side effect functional or a cell health
side effect to observe this and you
didn't observe
any of this with these compounds so
of course this is too hard because a red
red tinted is not a disorder but there
is a component that's a paper for
treatment so how you translate this
uh research so one thing that we found
is that uh there is a clinical compound
that's in
in clinical and phase three of clinical
trials that's nfx273
and this is a sigma one receptor agonist
so we decided to use
a similar compound also in this class
but also sigma one receptor agonist
to see if you can uh do a clinical
uh translation of this compound based on
what's is most
promising right now for for red enemy
and
we did observe that those uh dependent
rescue of israel
using this class of compounds used two
compounds in this class both
had some fibonacci so it was a very good
indication of that
compounds of sigma 1 receptor avenues it
can move forward so we were
based on the data that's coming out of
the clinical trial with nfx
um if it's positive is a good indication
that these models
can be used to identify compounds to
move improve clinical research
as well so finally just to summarize
uh this part to human ips derived
mesothelioids they can
in functional succeed in virtue we do
observe a highly homogeneous functional
phenotype on red steroids
um using this uh platform we need by 27
compounds
on the primary screen is able to rescue
the phenotype of the red
type that you have and the hits
that we select to move forward with
these compounds uh
they did uh show a recovery of redskins
and secondary screens uh in the
secondary you use the dot
dot response and flipper synaptic ponta
and
in a electrophysiological this is a very
promising platform to
to move compounds forward so
with that i would like to first
acknowledge
people that were involved in this work
and also the
organizers for for the event that allows
this um
we present the work here so thank you
very much everyone for everything